there's a cold wind blowing as the
Explorer Academy ship Orion set sail for
the frigid North Atlantic and hopefully
far away from the shadowy dangers and
mysterious events surrounding
twelve-year-old cruise Coronado's first
months at school
finally at see the young explorers get
to immerse themselves in real
expeditions cool classes and amazing
technology and with the help of his
friends crews secretly works to uncover
a cryptic message his mother left behind
before she died yet every discovery
leads to more questions and more enemies
was his mother's death really an
accident
will he uncover the missing formula who
can he trust the one thing crews knows
for sure nebula is still out to get him
making his mission more important and
more dangerous than ever
but nebulous secret and the Falcons
feather are available wherever books are
sold
[Music]